well joining us now on al jazeera is
vahe gergovian who's armenia's deputy
foreign minister his life from yerevan
thank you very much sir for speaking to
us as you heard there the armenians are
accusing the azeri's rather accusing
armenia of a large-scale provocation
how do you respond
i
certainly what happened
this
what happened
at midnight
today
is a large-scale
military offensive by azerbaijan
initiated on
on the border of armenia but also inside
of the territory of armenia
armenian
military installation and also civilian
infrastructure were targeted by
azerbaijan
i heard from previous speakers that
azerbaijan is not interested in blame
game
however facts suggest different
reality armenia has always been
interested in building security
across border with azerbaijan
and on number of occasion
armenia has proposed to work together
to the escalate
situation and to undertake security and
confidence building measures which would
not allow
to violate ceasefire and then initiate a
blame game but what is doing is exactly
the opposite
so
on november 26 2021
armenia azerbaijan and russia agreed on
building security on the border but it's
azerbaijan who is refusing to
undertake those security building
measures under that same agreement sir
if i can interrupt you just for a second
uh because uh the the
uh azeri's of course are saying the
contrary to what you're telling us right
now under that agreement which you just
mentioned armenia had agreed to withdraw
all of its troops from the contested
nagorno-karabakh region by september
what what is happening with that
armenian troops starting to pull back
i'm sorry it's outright disinformation
first of all there is no such a kind of
agreement
between armenia and azerbaijan i refer
to november 26 trilateral agreement and
that agreement does not contain anything
similar what you have described
and
november 26
trilateral statement clearly
states that
parties armenian azerbaijan should build
security should undertake measures to
reduce tensions on the borders but it's
azerbaijan who is refusing to implement
these trilateral statement okay so just
to
clarify again so when the azeri said
that armenia had agreed to pull back its
troops from the border this is not what
you agreed as far as you're concerned
mean this is uh i mean it's ridiculous
uh no any state would withdraw its
troops from southern territory i mean i
don't know
what is the
misperception around this issue that
armenia should withdraw its troops from
its borders but
armenia is a sovereign country it's a
member of united states
it's a member of united nations and thus
armenia has all rights for self-defense
okay now francis said it wants to raise
this latest escalation to uh the u.n
security council do you support the
european union's role here in this
dispute
i mean we are looking forward to
cooperate with all those who can
contribute uh towards peace in our
region
and uh of course
uh we understand that
uh
there are certain
countries organizations which offer
their good offices and of course we are
using those
good offices in order
to
to come to the peace to our region
can you tell us sir about the status of
the russian peacekeepers uh who were at
the border who were supposed to be
keeping the peace there what is their
current status
i mean let's uh
just uh there is i think we need uh uh
to
to clarify one thing russian
peacekeepers they are in
nagorno-karabakh sure and
they are
uh they are not on the border between
armenia and azerbaijan they are on
nagorno-karabakh and they play key role
in
ensuring
security for the people of nagorno-kara
and they are deployed there by the
trilateral
statement of november
9 2020
so the the areas where the fighting has
been happening in the last few hours
tell us a bit more about their
significance to your country
first of all it should be established
that the the situation remains very
tense
and hostilities are not stopped
elsewhere
they are still ongoing hostilities in
different sections of the border
and
this
and as i said
azerbaijan not merely
not nearly a violated ceasefire
across border but it also targeted
armenian positions and also civilian
infrastructures inside armenia
so it's a clear attack on sovereign
country its clear attack on u.n member
state
thank you very much for taking the time
to speak to us vahe gargovian armenia's
deputy foreign minister joining us there
from yerevan thank you